[Music]
the NRA a group that feels about guns
the way the rest of us feel about
natella a little is good more is better
and you can tell me it's bad for me all
you like but you will pry it from my
cold dead hands now in the wake of the
parklands shooting the NRA has found
themselves in the spotlight once more
however the public pressure this time is
actually starting to take a toll Twitter
users are pressuring companies
affiliated with a gun rights group by
using the hashtag boycott NRA so 15
companies have cut ties with the NRA
after Parkland I think we have a list of
them here some big ones you know Delta
United a Viet hurts basically saying
they're no longer going to provide
discounts to the NRA yes ie this budget
and Hertz will all stop providing
discounts to NRA members which will
presumably come as a huge blow to Jeremy
the one NRA member who was just in it
for the rental cars but the boycott
train hit a bit of a snag when it ran
into one of the NRA lesser-known side
ventures one group that hasn't been
swayed yet big tech companies like Apple
Amazon and Roku you see these companies
streaming services still offer access to
NRA TV the gun lobby groups free online
channel focused on pro-gun content okay
so that is an uncomfortable situation
for Apple and Amazon but it's a
miracle for Roku hurry hurry get in here
someone just called us a big tech
company they said like Amazon and Apple
it's happening Harry
all of the discussion this week of
boycotting NRA TV we thought it might be
worth answering the question what the
is that
because the truth is you may have
actually seen tiny bits of its
programming without even realizing it
like when this video featuring NRA
spokesperson Dana lash went viral just
last year they use their media to
assassinate real news they use their
schools to teach children that their
president is another Hitler the only way
we stop this the only way we save our
country and our freedom is to fight this
violence of Lies with a clenched fist of
truth yes the clenched fist of truth
which if you're looking for it is just a
little past the bent elbow of nonsense
and hiding in the overstuffed pocket of
needlessly aggressive metaphors now if
you miss that one you may have seen
another one that made the rounds during
the Obama administration featuring
country music legends Charlie Daniels to
the Hyatt olace of Iran and every
terrorist you enable listen up you might
have met our fresh-faced flower child
president is we need Ivy League friends
but you have a better America you
haven't been to Heartland
where the people will defend this nation
with their bloody calloused bare hands
you haven't meant to Steelworkers the
hard rock miners or the swamp folks in
Cajun country who can wrestle a
full-grown Gator out of water you
haven't met the hill demons who can
curse you and your future offspring just
for having a picnic in the wrong place
you haven't met the lake dog
he's a dog who lives in a lake for
reasons too complicated to get into at
the present moment and you haven't even
met the Gators down in Cajun country who
tiptoe out of the water at night and
take revenge on the swamp folk while
they sleep thus perpetuating the sick
cycle of swamp folk Gator violence
that's the America I know and I promise
you you're gonna be confused another one
of their promos was passed around online
and you may recognize one of the faces
in it and drinking as many as 12 diet
cokes the Second Amendment is about a
militia and it's the National Rifle
Association we are the press who's under
attack the president is like a child
certain people shouldn't have guns how
stupid do you think we are bless your
heart
[Applause]
[Music]
now don't laugh he's absolutely right
and if NRA members are annoyed with what
I'm saying right now they should do the
exact same thing and smash their
expensive televisions with large
sledgehammers are you listening NRA
members destroy your own property it's a
really good idea and it's honestly the
only way we'll learn now NRA TV produces
a lot of videos like those that are
essentially just trolling for your
attention but their content goes much
much deeper than that as you will see if
you go to their website or if you watch
it on streaming devices like the great
and powerful Roku NRA TV has news
programming and there's honestly not
really much point in our showing you any
of that because it's essentially just
Fox News on a much lower budget what is
what is more surprising is they make
shows lots and lots of shows and they
are so much stranger than you would
think so tonight let's watch some NRA TV
together because it's fascinating
now some shows are pretty similar to
ones that you would see anywhere on TV
with the key difference that there is a
gun involved
for instance they have three different
Antiques Roadshow knock-offs in which
men who look like this guy gets
progressively more and more aroused by
the guns they're holding what's unique
is that it has such flowing lines its
artwork it's a sensuous gun that's the
kind of pistol that when I hold or when
John is holding it gives me shivers the
idea was is that you in town talk both
hammers yes same time that man is duck
Wicklund and I love him but not as much
as he loves guns in fact the only way he
could love them anymore is if instead of
bullets every gun just fired a bunch of
little guns which in turn fired a bunch
of even smaller guns which in turn fired
tiny dog Wicklund living in a state of
sexual ecstasy inside the womb like
paradise of a firearm and while that
show is pretty sedate NRA TV also has
programming for the testosterone-fueled
gun enthusiasts like Media Lab in which
a former Navy SEAL named Dom Rosso
the very important work of reenacting
movies he likes from White House down to
Jack Reacher and here he is reenacting
scenes from the movie heat the main part
of this movie that I wanted to break
down was the fact that they're shooting
moving and communicating and if we get
past the fact that they're robbing a
bank if you're actually in a specific
uniform with specific kit can you shoot
move communicate with that amount of
weight and do down mandrills that's the
key thing here I would love to see a
bank robber I try to use that defense in
court Your Honor I really feel we need
to get past the fact that we were
robbing a bank and instead focus on how
well we were shooting moving and
communicating and the endearing thing
about Dom Rosso is that he shows
reenactments don't always go smoothly
for instance how did his reenactment of
the heat robbery go they make it look
easy the way they're moving there this
Bay has that was run was just hitting at
the back of my knees have taken my legs
out from underneath me definitely
fatigued me my strap broke so I was
holding it like this the entire time
wobbling back and forth even in the
beginning couldn't get a stable shooting
platform and we worked it out had to
lower my center gravity more so the bag
couldn't control me
we definitely proved that they didn't
have any weight in there while they were
shooting move it wow that is genuinely
inspiring because somewhere out there
there's an eight-year-old
watching that show and thinking oh good
being an adult is literally exactly how
I imagined it honestly I could talk
about Dom wrestle all night but before
we move on I have to show you his
inexplicable response to one viewer
submitted question what is your most
treasured possession I would say my art
gave me a cross that was made out of
bone she's like your
great-great-grandfather gave that to me
to pass down to somebody special in the
family but it was actually made out of
human bone and he carved it when he was
a prisoner of war
and that has been passed down on the
family now Mike are you serious I'm like
it just doesn't exist so that's probably
by far the coolest thing they have
well that's a hell of the story verdad
and I just don't know of any better
poster boy for the NRA than someone who
reenacts bank robberies for fun and
whose most treasured possession is a
cross made out of human bones but look
NRA TV isn't all gun bros there's also a
large amount of content aimed explicitly
at women there's even a whole women's
channel featuring shows like armed and
fabulous the NRA is actually making a
big push for women and they are pretty
clear about their motivations women
really have an incredible growth right
now in the NRA they are excited they're
enthusiastic they're there for us and
that's you know if you get the woman you
get the family if you get the woman you
get the family that is a brazenly
transparent statement of your marketing
strategy but to be honest can we just go
back to that room for a second did you
find that room relaxing is that a
soothing space for you
because I would be a little disturbed by
the extended family of gazelles
screaming why at me with their dead
glassy eyes now one of the NRA's female
focus programs love at first shot is
explicitly about getting women more
comfortable with the idea of owning or
firing guns and in one episode they took
a woman who was nervous about firearms
and really threw her in the deep end
they were gonna go straight into rifles
I'm gonna do it with an ar-15 okay I
know you've probably heard about them on
the news yes I hit the target you did
not as scary as I think I was
anticipated exactly it's just a nice
light push happiness yep a light puffs
of happiness it's a little weird to
describe a semi-automatic rifle the way
Bob Ross describes a cloud
but but once love at first shot has
women hooked the upselling begins which
does actually make sense industry
research has shown that women will spend
hundreds of dollars on accessories in
addition to their guns so you can kind
of understand why love at first shot
functions as a kind of QVC for firearms
showcasing products like mag loaders
targets gun cases and handbags okay so
as you see here I've got a couple of
different style options for you there
are a lot of different varieties of
exteriors but a lot of them really have
the same structure in terms of concealed
carries I never would have imagined
these little neat pockets and hidden
closures knowing that you can close it
it does put my mind at ease of that so
it's pretty cool go you don't even need
a gun because people are going to die
when they see that bag and look it's not
just handbags even the gun itself can be
profitably accessorized so yes we do
have a custom line of gun paint for the
ladies out there these mags look
phenomenal I love this product it's so
much fun to work with and it's great to
be able to put your own personal touch
on your firearms and your accessories oh
that's so fun that is so fun
oh if natalie ever commits murder a
grave oversight
good news chief the mag says the
killer's name right on it we don't know
what motivated them to go on a killing
spree but we do know she had a lot of
fun with it we've watched every single
episode of love at first shot and I have
to show you our favorite clip it's from
season 2 episode 1 the host natalie is
pregnant at this point so she can't join
in on the shooting but that doesn't mean
they didn't find a way to get her
involved we are going to make art for
Natalie since she couldn't be on the
range with us we're gonna do something
special for her to hang in her baby
nursery we know that you're expecting
obviously really thought we would make a
little something for it the baby's
nursery they shot paint so when somebody
inevitably asks why you have what
appears to be a blank canvas with a
large blood stain hanging up in your
Charles nursery you'll be able to
completely reassure them by saying oh
yeah my friend shots that for me but it
is not all fun with guns where an RA T V
really comes into its own is when its
tongue gets much darker which it does
for instance they have a series of
hunting videos which shouldn't be
surprising in fact it makes complete
sense people do use guns when they hunt
but while the visuals are predictable
Beauty shots of nature the voiceover
takes a different path somewhere over
this horizon sit a million little
dictators eager to purge humanity of its
hunting instincts the anti hunters had
imposed a false quarter
their lives based on a misconceived
perception of the world death is evil
they believe and so the purveyor of
death must also be evil death is an
undeniable fuel of life oh boy
God that is less planet Earth and more
deranged letter from a serial killer
although to be honest I would respect
the NR a a lot more if its slogan were
just the NRA because death is an
undeniable fuel of life I would like it
but at least we be clear where they were
coming from and that flowery vaguely
threatening tone is a key feature of NRA
TV here is another weird example hidden
beneath the dense canopy of deciduous
trees as a prostitute of sorts and those
who profit by selling her will stop at
nothing to exploit her sold and promoted
for her non-addictive even medicinal
advantages what lies behind the veil of
this seductress is far different than
what she first appears to be she is a
Harvard and her name is Mary Jane
[Music]
I didn't think this was possible but I
think that guy's just slut-shamed
marijuana and don't get me started on
mushrooms those filthy tramps they'll
grow next to any tree at all pause with
spores that's what I call them and if
you are wondering why NRA TV is even
talking about drugs at all the final
defining characteristic of the network
is painting a bleak vision of America
with threats around every single corner
and one solution next attack on our soil
could come in a matter of minutes
teenage girls are trafficked in sex
trade today's America is plagued by
urban riots and domestic Isis
sympathisers a natural disaster
you may call 9-1-1 and there may be
nobody on the other line the drug
cartels and the human traffickers who
have invaded our borders and embedded in
every single American city this threat
is real
our leaders are either incapable of or
unwilling to protect you and the ar-15
is one of the most effective tools
available to protect yourself and your
family holy they're using the same
techniques as an infomercial there is
human traffic getting you down do you
have Isis sympathisers in those
hard-to-reach places being tired of
getting 911 s there's got to be a better
way try the ar-15 available at way too
many stores near you now to watch NRA TV
is to watch a constant stream of stories
like those many of them real but
amplified to terrify you and sell you
products and there may be a good reason
that it sounds like an infomercial
because it is many of NRA TV shows are
sponsored by gun brands like Smith &
Wesson and behind the scenes of NRA TV
is an ad agency
it's called Ackerman McQueen they've
worked with the NRA for decades and the
Ackerman McQueen web site proclaims
every brand must be its own media
company and that is what the NRA have
done with their TV arm they've got a
product to sell and they employ people
who can sell that product well even Dana
lash the clenched fist of truth when
she's not warning a
the drug cartels and human traffickers
in every single American city
she's just selling you some other
hi i'm dana lash from the danish oh
there's one super food i drink every day
for healthy circulation and to make me
feel great all day long it's called
super beats and you can try for yourself
risk free i take super beats as my
pre-workout in the morning and as a non
jittery pick-me-up in the afternoon and
just one teaspoon of super beats gives
you the benefit of three whole beets Wow
Dana 3 whole beets
that's more than my delicious superfood
medium beats it gives you the benefits
of two whole beets which is and this is
true enough that's a perfectly adequate
number of beats the point the whole
point here is the answer to the question
what the is NRA TV is it's just a
vessel to sell America guns that's
pretty much it does it work it's
honestly hard to say they won't reveal
their rating so it's plausible that no
one is watching this and that that ad
agency akima McQueen are making out like
bandits
but look having having watched a
shitload of NRA TVs programming here is
what I'll say about it there is a lot to
be concerned about regarding the NRA s
activities but NRA TV might actually be
the dumbest most transparent thing that
it does think about it this way if the
NRA is a ferocious bear charging at you
NRA TV is that Bears ridiculous hat is
it i catching sure it is is it
perversely entertaining absolutely is it
the main thing you should be worried
about probably not because the real
truth here is hat or no hat it is
imperative that everyone keep their eyes
on that bear and now this and
now proof that NRA TVs tone can make
anything seem scary has your kitchen
that once believed in the south glow of
dawn
become a bleak gulag of countertops bent
and shameful submission to breakfast
perverse tyrant she is the ovens
contemptible and her name is
muffins the muffin is a gluttonous
prison each very a fruit slave within
its crusty walls Americans once relished
our right to a stack of flapjacks and a
cup of joe but now we tremble before
satan's cupcakes uncut and flapjacks
unstacked muffins rise we must rise
against death because you don't know the
muffin man america and you better pray
you'd never do pancakes the undeniable
fuel of life oh thank you so much for
watching see you next week good night
[Applause]